so at this point you know i've been
working on the map since
yesterday so as a team and then i get up
in the morning right away go through
okay quick changes
and we're running a little late today um
so as opposed to being like 5 45 or 6
it'll probably be the gym around 6 30.
uh i give it another once over in case
some news broke that we need to add
that's appropriate
and then jim shower shave when i do that
and then do a run-through where we make
our final lettuce so
it's a busy morning
isn't my breakfast every day
i'm approaching shake using a piece of
fruit
someone's coming thank you good morning
[Music]
two small sunrise batches please with a
little bit of cream
we have an espresso machine it's one of
the few like nice things that we have
and uh thank you because of a pregnant
wife right now it's it's decaf and it's
a
pain in the ass to change it so
duncan's the only thing open at five
this is this is all you need americans
the one thing that we get to run is way
too big our cups of coffee
cup of coffee is six ounces when they
say you can have three cups of coffee
this is already like a cup and a half
that's all you need i always just get
the extra small
and you're good
[Music]
here in the car
[Music]
uh
[Music]
um
just to confirm i've already done two
sets
six seven reps smooth manny let the
camera die
all right admit it i did you did i'm
sorry
my second set so i don't expect to get
six or seven
[Music]
[Music]
so now it's a shower show run through
then we go live first time on youtube
[Music]
good morning hey
[Music]
[Music]
i can't say favorite hand because but
[Music]
ahoy
[Music]
oh
[Music]
the monitor's aiming this way a little
too much
[Music]
okay thanks a lot i told you not to film
[Music]
um that was a wonderful sip from the
sencha green tea yeah i went i went full
uh
that was called appropriation yeah that
was good accenture green tea this is our
first time back on youtube cultural
appropriation month our first show back
on youtube people saying oh wait
are they gonna come back with cultural
appropriation month yes
that's a yeah so we're really excited
rumble right so you can watch this show
everything that's free on youtube will
still be free and i'd like to see at
least as many of you guys
tuning in watching on rumble to support
them if you're going to give your
dollars to some place
rumble is at least trying to do it yeah
right
and just please do not let us lose touch
[Music]
sex robot i told you to never come to my
work david
i want my money i don't have your money
don't give me that
i want my money you sound like a pimp
right now you're programmed to be a sex
slave
a sex robot see you later
i've never been more assumed to have
cultural appropriation okay
uh i don't even know oh now the legs are
crossed
[Music]
all right i gotta pee and then i have to
do a 3d sonogram later it's the first
[Music]
time
i don't know
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
as far as am i nervous about the surgery
honestly not
not really this is gonna sound this is
and this is not
a woe is me thing but i even uh when
talking with my
therapist told her like oh man i would
love
to have when my therapist like do you
think you could have
a period where you can like take a full
month or take a couple months off
because
that's important for someone to do in a
high compression scenario and i thought
oh
if i just had like some serious health
problem then i could take time off and
people wouldn't be
mad at me like you know you can read the
comments like oh it's like because when
we're taking time off
we'll spend that you know we're not
we're not really taking time off like
sometimes it'll take
several weeks to upgrade the studio to
make sure that we have software licenses
like
the work that people see is such a small
fraction that i haven't actually taken
like a long vacation
in a while and this will be the closest
to that only i'll have
you know three titanium rods in my chest
and a lot of pain but
hopefully that's what painkillers are
for i was just trying to make sure that
i fit the pieces
you know like i won't be able to do any
any lifting they said more than 10
pounds
for like three months and that's not
gonna happen but
it's just sort of figuring out okay what
can i do when can i do it
um i won't be able to do jiu jitsu with
the bars in my chest but
i can coach it which um which i
which i enjoy more than even doing this
so i enjoy coaching the team here and
i'll be able to start training probably
three months after doing like lower body
stuff
it's just been more so piecing the
schedule
together than what i've been thinking
about but before that and as much as i
love
coaching because those who can't do
teach i'm okay
at grappling uh i think i'm better at
distilling it and coaching it
but still i'll i'll enjoy the the last
few weeks i have and
you know roll some people up i think
it's time for that a little bit
say so long to my love of controlled
violence
m
foreign
double double
[Music]
[Applause]
he's again canadian very polite he'd be
standing out there for hours
and then when he and then when you would
say you can come in he'd say sorry
sorry
[Music]
so
so you can see your right particular
outflow track would be smaller than what
we expect and as a result
your stroke volume potentially would be
less than what you would expect
contractility of the heart the motor is
working fine
you just have a boulder sitting on top
of the motor right so you look at it for
most individuals your age and gender
would be around 17 to 18 centimeters so
right off the bat
you're 4 out of 18 so about 20 lower
than i would expect
compression limited space or compression
just gets that much more
significant and as a result you go from
13.4 to 9.7
which is another 3.7 out of 13.7 so
there's another 25 percent decline the
right side of the stroke
position change so
your stroke volume is lower than what we
expected for somebody your age and
gender
really slow which most people can't do
when you tell them to
um well it's funny because i do stop
breathing often when i talk so that's
the thing that's
it's the perfect storm of the show i'm
talking a million miles a minute and
then
kind of leaning at least seated you know
sometimes leaning forward
um and yeah my pulse just
go it's always above like one-third but
uh my resting pulsar isn't
below 50's in the morning just baseline
we looked at stroke volume on you and so
when you're laying flat
your normal stroke volume is
well no normal is 16 17. but when you
sat
up and leaned forward you dropped all
the way to 9.7
and so that's really low so uh so you're
saying there's nothing else that would
explain these things and then the pectus
would see
is severe enough that it would you don't
live laying flat right
if you if you spend all your time lying
in bed you'd be fine
right right and you feel fine when
you're laying down most of the time
but you sit up and you lean forward and
you see that compression
from your pectus and everything you know
your heart starts speeding up we see it
we see it having to work harder in order
to get
push the blood through the only way it
can keep
up with the demands of your body to get
the oxygen
is to beat faster you know one of the
things that
is always hard to visualize is where the
bars go
we don't exactly have the bars perfect
inside him the bars
fit really nice and flush up inside in a
normal person
but only this much of the bars
is actually inside you behind your chest
okay
they're all inside you but only this
much is inside the chest
the rest of it is underneath the muscle
kind of here okay underneath and so when
we go to take them out
we open the little pocket we take these
little ties out then then we just slide
them out
and so getting them out is a relatively
easy procedure much easier than getting
them
in but
this business of going in between your
ribs and pushing out this
is what you know can be uncomfortable
right
on you because of your size that
probably you would use titanium bars on
you just because
the weight of your chest is a lot and so
the problem with the stainless steel
bars which i mean you can see
i mean i can bend this with my arm
[Music]
and so i mean you would flatten the bar
with
you know even three bars i mean so
titanium you can't bend like that
if i have titanium rods would that be
bulletproof
would it be um it would help you you
would be pretty close
you know you you would have like this
much of your body pretty much
good kind of something someone comes
over you yeah
there you go there's a silver lining
titanium lining i should say
but we're not our expectations are
you're not going to be normal
i'm not going to make you normal normal
um
let's turn the cameras off okay okay
[Music]
okay so by the time you watch this i
will have
gone under the knife as it were i guess
i don't know if they use knives whatever
it is that they use
and uh undergone the procedure to become
the bionic man um i appreciate the
prayers the well wishes but
uh yeah i'm actually uh i'm more so
looking forward to
the improvement uh afterwards so uh
i guess version 2.0
[Music]
you